we're going to talk about why you may
have sharp stomach pain that comes and
goes there are actually 10 reasons for
this specific symptom the first one is
something called SIBO and that stands
for a small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth now take a look at this you
have the small intestine right here and
you have the large intestine right here
sound normally you're supposed to have
all the bacteria or most of the bacteria
in the large intestine and not the small
intestine now you have some bacteria in
the small intestine but the majority is
in the large intestine where it ferments
especially fiber when you have an
imbalance we have too many microbes in
the small intestine what happens when
you eat especially probiotics because
you're actually taking in microbes or
fiber as in vegetables when the fiber
goes in here you see microbes start
eating the fiber and start to create
this fermentation so you get all this
gas and the microbes also will compete
for the nutrients so you end up becoming
deprived of nutrients because they're
pretty much eating everything that they
see normally you're not supposed to have
all those microbes in here instead
you're supposed to have enzymes
digesting the food from the pancreas and
the lining of the small intestine and
then breaking down the food and 90% of
it is supposed to be absorbed in the
small intestine so the worst thing to
consume when you have SIBO is vegetables
so this is a good time to be a carnivore
for a couple months so you can actually
clean this thing out and if you do have
SIBO and I have videos on it I'll put a
link down below you need to be taking
betaine hydrochloride to acidify the
stomach so you can kill off the microbes
in the stomach so they don't end up in
the small intestine number two let's say
you have a part of your intestine just a
part of it the the part that's at the
very end right here let's say this is
inflamed okay let's say you have a itis
which is inflammation of the ileum right
down over here and you eat food
and it goes through this long little
tube right here no pain no pain and then
it hits this area of inflammation that's
raw and you just start hurting okay so
if you have inflammation in a certain
part your colon that's why you get this
sharp stomach pain and this usually
comes from damage with something you're
eating whether it's a food allergy okay
like gluten for example or other
allergies in which case you need to do a
food allergy test and avoid those foods
so you can start healing this area so I
probably should just add gluten and food
allergies also if you have an ulcer in
part of your colon that can also cause
pain and by the way chlorophyll is a
great way to heal an ulcer all right
number three a gallbladder and the bile
duct so you got the liver right here
that makes bile it comes down into this
common bile duct it's a little tube and
it goes into the gallbladder where it's
concentrated and then when you eat this
same contracts and it pushes it out into
the small intestine with help of the
enzymes from the pancreas together so we
have bile plus lipase which is the
enzyme from the pancreas to help break
down fats but if you're eating the wrong
type of food or you have high levels of
estrogen or cortisol you can develop a
stone either in the gallbladder or on
the bile duct and that can create a lot
of irritation or if you're eating the
wrong type of foods like junk foods and
vegetable oils like corn oil or soy oil
which is highly inflammatory that can
irritate these ducts right here and
cause all sorts of pain and bloating
when it becomes distended okay that
pressure can cause pain so a problem
with the gallbladder and this bile duct
is very common I put some links down
below for you to get more data on that
area number four the pancreas or the
pancreatic duct okay so the pancreas
makes enzymes the pancreas also makes
insulin okay so it actually makes a
hormone actually several hormones and
enzymes
both functions if you're consuming too
many carbohydrates you're gonna cause
that pancreas to work really really hard
because it has to pump out a tremendous
amount of insulin now realize this
pancreas has a dual function it's making
hormones and it's also making enzymes so
if you're stimulating one part of the
pancreas you're also stimulating the
other part too so you're creating a big
strain and that can interfere with the
normal flow of digestive juices coming
through here and it can swell up and
cause all sorts of problems with pain
congestion especially sharp pain in
grains and it's probably the number one
reason why a lot of people have sharp
pain in their stomach and for some
people this could be literally poisonous
to their system and really create a lot
of damage into the small intestine
through here and again the food
knowledge is as well okay number six
fortification what do I mean by
fortification
well they enriched flour products with
iron and synthetic vitamins iron is a
very very toxic to the microbes and to
your body especially with men and
postmenopausal women who are not
menstruating and getting rid of their
their blood each month so our bodies
don't have a good ability to get rid of
excessive amounts of iron and iron is
very very damaging to our brains to our
gut and to the liver especially you can
create all sorts of issues including
cirrhosis so when someone's consuming
grains in America especially in Canada
in the UK it's fortified okay with iron
and that's one of the reasons why it
just tears up your stomach in other
countries that don't fortify that they
can somehow get away with consuming
grains and not have the bloating and the
digestive issues but they still have the
weight gain because it turns into carbs
pretty fast but the other thing that
European countries will do and other
countries around the world is that they
will make bread products a little bit
differently they'll make the dough and
then they'll let it for men
overnight as compared to the bread in
the US where they don't ferment it very
long
it ends up fermenting in your gut so you
feel a lot of bloating and anytime you
feel bloating you're gonna get pain
we've already talked about vegetable
oils these are like the soy oils canola
the corn oil cottonseed oil these are
highly inflammatory to the digestive
system and the amount of consumption of
these oils are off the charts and this
is hidden in a lot of foods especially
salad dressing mayonnaise and you're
consuming on a regular basis and not
even really realizing that this could be
the reason why you have all this pain in
your gut and then we have GMO grains so
this would be soy and corn and even
wheat is sprayed with glyphosate which
is the Roundup Ready which can really
irritate your digestive system and
affect these microbes number 9 low
stomach acid this is very very common if
you don't have enough acid in your
stomach what's going to happen is the
food is going to go through here
slightly undigested and as the food is
not digested up here it ends up down
here creating a huge strain and you're
gonna get abnormal fermentation bloating
and pain a simple problem you just need
to add outside of vinegar and betaine
how to chloride and problems solved and
last thing is frequent eating if you're
doing six meals a day three meals with
three snacks not a good idea when you do
it with fasting you allow the gut to
heal and rest so if you're experiencing
sharp pain and you're getting bloating
you really need to do in a minute
fasting it's the absolute best thing to
do it gives your whole system a chance
to reset and heal as far as protein goes
you don't want to do too much you want
to do a moderate amount because too much
protein can also overload the digestive
system especially if you don't have
enough stomach acid and also you want to
keep your carbs lower because that can
really irritate the liver and the
gallbladder and especially the pancreas
and normally I recommend a lot of
vegetables but not if you have SIBO
alright thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next video and if you haven't
already subscribed click the red button
below and that little Bell icon so you
can be notified of all the new videos
that I'm gonna be releasing and I have
some very cool and interesting videos
coming up in the next coming weeks plus
in addition to that you'll be notified
of the live Q&A sessions that I'm going
to be doing throughout the week and you
don't want to miss those as well
so stay tuned for more great content